Hám thông tần Trung mong triệu viên Cà xe nữa, à đưa tin.
Đại hội lên thứ chiếm của đảng là động triệu viên đã bầu lại nhà lãnh đạo kìm trong ơn.
Dương trước, tổng bị thư.
Các đình được thông qua trong ngoài lần việc thứ thứ của đại hội với sự ủng hộ nhất chi của các đại biểu thầm dự.
Cà xe nữa, cho biết việc nhà lãnh đạo kìm trong ơn tại đất cụ trực dành trong bị thư.
Phản anh ý khi kênh định vàng, về nguệnh bọng nhất chi của phản thề đảng viên của nhân và nhân dân.
Trong bật từng thật, cà xe nữa, a càng người ổng kìm đã cùng có vá trò lãnh đạo của đảng.
Nên cao bị thế cu ra và tăng cụ xương mạnh quân sự, trong đó nhân mạnh năng lực ra đây hạt nhân được cảnh thiện một cách tăng bản về sự lãnh đạo của ông.
Đây hội đảng chiến khai mặt ngày 12 tại Biíong, có những vụ tổng kết việc thực hiện hịt quết nhập kì trước,
và đe ra phương phát triển trong ra đỏ mới cho chil tiền.
Đây hội cũng bầu bán trước phản chung ngôi mới, và thông qua sự đổi một số nội dung điều lẽ đạo.